hey guys on the go today I am with
what's inside do you guys want to
introduce yourselves
yes I'm Dan from what's inside and I
love that you have so many knives around
here this like right up our alley
they're probably my favorite thing I am
Lincoln and I look I like how you're too
nice to me and green and pink those are
like my two favorite colors so I thought
it was fitting so we take things apart
for our Channel and see what's inside of
them and we just did a really weird
video on our channel yeah it was weird
what was the the expiration date on set
the 1991 and and I don't really know
what this is inside of this box so
excited to see what's inside of this so
I think you can Apple to see but I'm not
sure I order this look eBay a long time
ago and then I got upset because I
realized after I'd purchase it won the
auction
there is no monitor so we're gonna open
it up see what's inside because I
actually am not sure do you know what an
apple to see is I absolutely know Clive
oh well this is old let me see when this
was this is probably one is older the
thing that we would get on our channel
or the thing on your channel because
when that thing was because this says
the release date was April 24th 1984 oh
wow so okay Wow retro I guess we just
what's inside it get it I have to be
careful I think it might have the
original box as well so I don't want to
cut through so what's the favorite thing
that you guys have opened up I really
like the Stretch Armstrong oh I did see
that that one yes it was really cool
because afterwards in the comments
people said if you could have which the
substance inside yeah tastes like sugar
because it was kind of made of sugar
wait I love the retro retro apples so
good nice can they bring back this logo
check out this box this is I mean this
is something that you've never even had
to experience in your lifetime we did a
world's first PC or personal computer
which is an IBM 5150 I think it was in
1981 when they came out with it and it
was kind of the computer that was
mass-produced in a way so much so that
they they coined the term like PC yeah
so Apple back in the day it came out
great products but it just wasn't like
for the masses I guess no it wasn't and
they were very expensive which is still
something that does carry over today
yeah it's the Apple to see and the
problem is there's no monitor with this
but this is the original packaging
there's no Street there's no screen yeah
hopefully just had this though like this
was not planned yeah so you know and
she's like you know what I think what's
in temper tech Park that I have around
here let me go grab my Apple to see from
1984 she's sitting in that closet
well looks I think you didn't have
monitor so I thought that I'd never be
able to really do this video so let's I
guess now this is what is this tape
source for you tape is it's to wrap your
ankle with yeah yeah tearing the I'll
let you go inside Terry Wilson I said
they put that over top of that
oh hey guys what's inside you make this
joke oh yeah I'm sure this is this looks
like it is all the original packaging
though which is cool really does Oh
could you play fort night with this
joystick program it properly
no this is your building right there
then you run good I'm sure you can see
the logo on how to fill out have you
done it oh that's very heavy the plastic
definitely took natural it does
you know the way that we operate
whenever we see something old we just
always want to take it apart and see
what's inside but this is this is
probably something you don't want to
take apart it's so old and historical
and you can use it as a briefcase
raising your and going to work take
about computer that's like a laptop like
one of the industrial like PC or like
the the gaming laptops that they have
like this like this size what in the
world it says look look at this there's
bumps on B and K instead of Jane F
that's what they usually tell you know
yeah cuz that's where you supposed to
put your fingers no tight I don't know
that you didn't know I know there's
bumps I just didn't realize which keys
the really shy put your fingers on but
if they're usually on J and s oh thanks
kids know these days I like typing oh
yeah that is interesting
yeah whatever that page I like them
chemical keyboard this is kind of
there's actually a whole subreddit
dedicated to mechanical keyboards that
people will go on they just love the
sound of it and they love the feel of it
yeah there we go
do some typing here for you guys is our
to see it does sound good though I like
it
it's so cool this is awesome I mean we
plug it in and just see what happens I
think we're on a monitor yeah and I'd
say we take it apart it's so cool who
knows if it works monitor has a superior
gyrus I mean now how does it get a
monitor this is the quarter yeah maybe
it's an extension cable I bet I'll logo
is on the little plug this is really
cool so I plug it in I think we just
have to turn it on see if it does so
much okay Oh disk fusion power is behind
okay do that again that sound was really
cool okay did you hear that yeah okay
what this thing is pretty rad so that's
kind of crazy because it is turning on
now I mean even if there's no monitor it
still works
yeah we just can't see what's on the
screen so you can just type and it's
doing something if there watch the
screen that's pretty cool yeah I mean
it's turning on so that's a good thing
you don't have an old Apple computer
laying around somewhere anybody was
still in monitor from so I do but that
one is also not unboxing look this is
amazing I mean this is where the floppy
discs go oh I love floppy how so cool
yeah you know you wouldn't say that if
that's what you had to use back in the
day
never yeah I still have puffy disks that
have my storage stuff on it for when I
was a kid so I got this on eBay for
let's see how much should I pay for this
I was like this is a great deal it's a
hundred and thirty-two dollars
thinking that I was never won $50 for
this yeah oh I thought you were gonna
say something like I don't know thousand
dollars you know that's why I was so
excited about it
this was discontinued in August 1988 the
introductory price was 1295 which is
equivalent to $3,000 in 2017 technically
it was more portable easy to use it is
actually pretty portable yeah it has a
handle built-in cards in poor you can
see at the monitor see if that has a
hand right walking down the street here
it is and here's
the monitor that box is so cool I just
want to cut that logo off right there I
would like to cut this up and like get
it free Bob yeah that would be a good
idea this is weird
it says to control is right here but
caps lock is way down here yeah so I
just got to that so the keyboard layout
mirrored that in the Apple 2e so however
the resent key had been moved above the
Escape key
so the reset key so escape is here so he
says be there it's usually over here by
the power yeah how are you so sure
they're there add-on accessories oh my
gosh look at this oh I'm going shopping
this is an athlete's flat panel display
so you can attach it somehow on this
chip okay that is cool I have never seen
this before I've no ever ever ever ever
been an animal museum before I've never
seen this movie before
oh so this is an accessory so that's a
monitor but this is the he'll little
accessory it would be cool to see how
you could connect that yeah I mean I
think it's probably just connected
through like the the monitor port 128
kilobytes of RAM
bye-bye yes but you could upgrade it to
one point one two five megabytes this is
so cool what I'm excited to test this
out and potentially get a monitor but
that little LCD display is super cool I
could see you get that do you even know
I was in Prague and I went yes museums
they have one there and it's amazing
it's like just randomly you're walking
down the streets and all of a sudden BAM
I was like wait a NAPA Museum we need to
go I bought the tickets online we went
through the most exciting that ever but
I did not see that LCD display we've had
opportunities to destroy some old Apple
tech yeah just kind of said I'd let's
let's let that be I think if it's
something is not working it's fine but
like if this turned on so is like we can
and it'll be a cool noise just and you
can make it accessory honest yes this is
so cool I'm so excited that this
actually turned on I have a bunch of
other old tech bit I'm gonna be doing
videos of it's just like it's not timely
so I can just have it sit up there cuz
clearly this has been around for 34
years already yeah there's no hurry for
unboxings yeah and let us know
once you open that adjusting Apple
Museum because we want to come to the
like grand opening party you can come
see what's inside
all the jokes the child listen well this
is great thank you guys and so glad that
we could experience this together
I'm so excited though because we also
did a video on their channel where we
ate something that was almost as old as
this computer well I didn't eat it I'm
sorry I did yesterday I didn't want to
and I didn't need that it's been about
two hours and I'm still feeling okay so
what's good it's good too far so far
okay thank you so much go check out
their channel I'll put all the links in
the description go subscribe and make
sure you hit the bell because the Bell
is so important yeah yeah the finger
Bell yeah subscribe Bell see you later
bye
[Music]
you